so of course we're starting with the
major news that special counsel Robert
Muller has provided his report to Donald
Trump's Attorney General William Bar
we're finally going to see exactly
what's in molars report except we're not
all we have is an initial summary four
pages written by Donald Trump's attorney
General William Barr who wrote a memo
last year saying he doesn't believe a
president can be indicted for
obstruction of justice regardless of
what the evidence says he has put
together a four-page summary as he sees
it Muller submitted his report on Friday
Barr released a four-page summary
yesterday on Sunday and I've read dozens
of articles and analyses many of which
are missing key factual data in terms of
what we know and what we don't know
many of the analyses either with sort of
irrelevant incomplete or strawman
analyses of the situation so I'm going
to make an effort to provide something
of value here that will have two goals
reduce confusion and increase general
understanding of what it is that is
going on and my prediction is nobody
will be pleased with my analysis and
assessment here just based on the tweets
I've been getting over the last 24 hours
so let's set this up as I have been
saying for more than a year now if
Democrats want a shot in 2020 they can't
be relying on a molar report that is
going to lead to Donald Trump's
impeachment or indictment or removal
because it's an outrageous standard and
it's a very unlikely expectation and in
fact anyone who's been waiting around
for sort of smoking gun video evidence
of Donald Trump colluding with Russia
that was a crazy expectation to begin
with and it's something I've been
arguing about a lot with callers on both
the right and left on the show for the
last year that's just not a reasonable
expectation it's not a good political
strategy it's unlikely to ever come to
fruition and indeed that appears to have
been confirmed by Robert Miller so far
although of course we need the full
report everything we know right now is
based on a four page summary done by
William Bar Trump's attorney general who
was handpicked specifically to mitigate
the damage of the Moller investigation
this is a sanitized interpretation of
the Moller report written by the guy who
said a year ago you can't indict a
president for obstruction of justice
many people believe that we now know the
full extent of the Moller report we
don't all we have is a four-page summary
from Trump's Attorney General William
bar the interesting thing to consider is
that imagine for a moment that since the
start of this investigation we saw
nothing the investigation was carried
out in silence and there were no
indictments all along there were no
convictions all along there were no jail
and prison sentences all along
restitution and to the tune of millions
and millions of dollars if on friday
robert muller had announced my
investigation is now complete
we are indicted 37 people or whatever
the number is here are the ones who have
already pled guilty here are the ones
where we already have guilty verdicts
here is the amount of money that they
are going to be subject to in terms of
penalties and repayments for fraud and
other financial crimes and here's the
number of years cumulatively that they
are going to be spending in prison
immediately the reaction would be that
is a stunning and overwhelming result
the number of indictments the number of
years of prison time the amount of
information that has been gathered but
because over time we had one indictment
and another indictment and a guilty plea
etc when Robert Muller says this is as
far as I go I understand that it seems
extraordinarily anticlimactic but
there's still a lot of important stuff
to be gathered even from what William
bar has released so far number one the
Special Counsel has referred several
matters to other offices for further
action this confirms that the SD NY and
a number of other investigations are
going to continue and there may be
future indictments there are they going
to be for Trump colluding with Putin in
the cartoonish way that some were hoping
for from the beginning of course not of
course not that was never a realistic
number two the investigation did not
establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired or coordinated with
the Russian government in its election
interference exactly as expected we we
did not believe that Trump was going to
be caught red-handed interestingly
imagine any Democrat getting an email
from Russians saying we'll help your dad
win and then the son of the candidate
says they love it and then they have the
meeting and then the Russians help and
then your campaign chairman Paul manna
forgives polling data to Russia and your
hand-picked attorney general says
there's nothing to see here but we'll
put that aside for now because in the
end it is the sort of conclusion that we
expected Trump was never going to be
caught red-handed
colluding with Putin personally unable
to exonerate Trump from obstruction of
justice is another interesting element
of the report the report says that
Robert Muller evaluated evidence when it
comes to obstruction cannot say that the
president definitively obstructed
justice but also cannot exonerate the
president from having obstructed justice
that's important and it is being left up
to Donald Trump's attorney General
William Barr to determine if obstruction
of justice took place
I wonder what William Bars opinion will
be as to whether Donald Trump obstructed
justice and this is where you realize
that Donald Trump's appointment of
William Barr is working exactly as
designed Barr was partially selected
because it was known that he doesn't
think a president can be indicted for
obstruction Barr wrote a memo more than
a year ago saying he doesn't believe you
can indict a president for obstruction
of justice and now William Barr is in
the position of deciding based on the
evidence does he think charges of
obstruction of justice are warranted for
the president I can let you know right
now it's not happening it is simply not
happening and any Democrat who now is
going to sort of hang their hat on well
we need to make sure William Barr
decides to indict or prosecute or
whatever for obstruction it's just not
happening the guy said a year ago that
he just doesn't think a president can be
indicted for that it's just not going to
happen very interesting element from
William bars report that's not getting a
lot of attention is that it confirms
that indeed it was Russians who hacked
the Clinton campaign in the DNC this was
a primary assertion that many on the
right denied all along they said no it
wasn't really the Russians who hacked
the DNC and the report from bar
summarising molars report also says that
the Russian hacks of DNC and Clinton
material were disseminated by WikiLeaks
remember that there were huge
contingents on the right and left which
were saying there is no evidence
whatsoever that WikiLeaks was connected
to the Russian hacks if you except
William bars claims about collusion
don't you also have to accept Williams
bars claims about WikiLeaks his
connection to Russia if not you're being
extraordinarily inconsistent that's not
been discussed in any significant way
since yesterday's four-page release from
William bar so there's a common refrain
from the right which is see Trump wasn't
actively working with Russia I want to
know who was saying Trump will be caught
red-handed having worked with Russia I
can't actually think of anyone who was
saying that certainly not on this
program we have insisted that Donald
Trump through sort of being a guy who
wants to be liked by everybody and
through previous financial issues has
been sort of lulled into this situation
of indifference to people in his
campaign taking help from Russia and
indifference to Russia actively working
to help him defeat Hillary Clinton but
the defense that see Trump didn't do it
is not really refuting anything that
serious people were saying about this I
also want to mention that there hasn't
been any serious reporting on this
summary which addresses sort of what one
of the major issues which is what even
was and was not investigated here
because
the report if you believe bars summary
focuses the investigation only on very
specific questions about Trump quote
collusion when we know that this is also
much bigger than that and on that I
think the left is basically united from
what I've been seeing in the last 24
hours
the left wing commentators seem
basically united on the idea that this
doesn't mean nor did anyone say Trump
has committed no crimes but that the
specific collusion caught red-handed
expectation for people who had that was
maybe misguided or simply inaccurate so
the next step is the full report has to
be made public period the the word of
Donald Trump's Attorney General who was
picked because at least in part he
doesn't think a president can be
indicted for obstruction that can't be
allowed to stand as the official record
of what is and isn't in the report if
there's nothing damaging in the report
Trump who now feels vindicated and
exonerated should want the report
released my guess is he'll fight it
because the full report probably does
contain a bunch of damaging details that
simply don't rise to the level of enough
evidence to indict Donald Trump on this
issue of collusion again the report
doesn't rule out obstruction of justice
it does put it in the hands of Donald
Trump's Attorney General I imagine that
there are specifics in the full report
related to that another sort of point of
perspective here that that I want to add
is that anybody who's calling this an
exoneration or a vindication seems to be
either deliberately or inadvertently
missing or not understanding what's
being said this is a four page summary
which actually says Trump has not been
exonerated on the issue of obstruction
but the real message is if you're hoping
he gets charged with obstruction in
order to remove him from office in 2020
I've been telling you for more than a
year now I wouldn't be holding my breath
and if we can take sort of like a
positive perspective on this hopefully
this helps the left by confirming that
the Moller probe was never going to be a
get-out-of-jail-free card
I put Trump in jail free card I guess
maybe better said voting in November of
2020 is going to be the way to remove
Donald Trump and now we have to make
sure that everybody understands that
last thing on this I want to just
briefly address the portion of the left
that sees this as vindicating Trump and
it's not a huge portion again most
people on the Left understand collusion
red-handed was not likely but Trump has
done a lot of things wrong including
money laundering and other crimes it is
a little strange to see some so-called
leftists who normally recognize that our
justice system is hugely biased along
privileged and racial and class lines
except that a 72 year old billionaire
president didn't actually do anything
because his hand picked the journey
Attorney General sort of said so in a
four-page summary and what I mean by
that is when the justice system tells us
that some black guy was selling pot and
it was dangerous and we've got to put
him in jail we understand that that's
the message that comes from a system
that is inherently biased and we
recognized that just because law
enforcement says something doesn't make
it true you can't believe that and at
the same time eagerly accept the summary
of William bar as an accurate
representation of reality as a total
representation of reality and along
those same lines when Trump Secretary of
State tells us Isis is defeated we
realize that's a political statement we
should be skeptical of that when Trump's
Secretary of Education tells us Trump is
winning on education we recognized that
she's a biased political actor so in the
same way when Trump's own Attorney
General comes in and says Trump is
cleared based on my selective summary of
Robert Moeller's report why aren't we
skeptical about accepting that as fact
as well that element really doesn't make
sense to me so listen I've agreed all
along that it's the cover-up it's the
obstruction it's the ancillary and
tangential crimes that that's really the
focus Trump was not going to be caught
red-handed colluding with Putin that's
not actually news and the fact that
anyone on the left or right sees that as
vindication suggests to me they're not
fully understanding the
tales of this initial summary of the
report and please don't forget that
until we see the actual report all we
have is a political document from a guy
who said from day one before day one
from last year I don't believe you can
indict a president for obstruction of
justice I look forward to hearing from
you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show one
of today's sponsors is minds.com a
social networking platform that is
committed to free speech transparency
privacy and fairly compensating content
creators it basically combines many of
the features of sites like Facebook
YouTube and Twitter in one platform but
mine's is trying to solve a lot of the
problems that exist on major social
networks on Minds you're not being spied
on you're not being tracked everything
is encrypted and private minds as a
company can't even see any of your
personal data you're not going to see a
bunch of creepy ads showing you the same
products you were just looking at on
other websites and unlike other major
social networks the code that runs
minds.com is publicly available it
provides total transparency and the
ability for developers to even
contribute to the project themselves for
example on many other social platforms
you're only reaching a tiny fraction of
your followers organically but on mine's
the newsfeed is 100% organic and you can
see for yourself how the algorithms
actually work every time you do
something on minds like create content
share like someone else's content you
earn minds tokens which can be used to
boost the visibility of your own content
you are getting rewarded for
participating in and contributing to the
network and Mainz offers a feature kind
of like patreon where your fans can
unlock your premium content by sending
you minds tokens I encourage you to go
check it out at minds.com there's also a
mobile app and you can actually follow
the david pakman show on minds at
minds.com
slash david pakman show I've also put a
link right underneath this video